Martin Gamache habite au chemin Fischer
une route parallèle à la frontière à
Ford il observe sur son terrain de plus
en plus de migrants traverser la
frontière pour entrer discrètement aux
États-Unis le véhicule uber qui a
débarqué dans mon entrée là il y a des
barqués dynamique Pedro histoire venu
ici à pied moi j'étais sur ma terrasse
il y a deux Mexicains qui ont sorti du
bois le Pedro avec son petit sac à dos
est allé les rejoindre à pied Martin a
même accueilli chez lui une famille
visiblement perdue et sans ressources il
y avait les pieds complètement mouillés
je l'ai il faisait moins 25 dollars elle
était complètement congelé la route même
si elle est courte n'est pas facile il
faut traverser ces bois et ses champs et
éviter les caméras bien cachées dans ses
arbres et tout le monde n'y arrive pas
le nombre d'interceptions par les agents
américains a explosé en quelques mois
passant de
300 mai dernier a presque 400 en
novembre et la tendance se poursuit
juste durant la première semaine de
janvier une centaine de personnes de 11
pays différents ont été arrêtés dans ce
secteur côté américain cette hausse
fulgurante Hélène Lavoie depuis sa
fenêtre un matin je me faisais un café
et il y avait une dame qui passait à
pied ou teint foncé avec un enfant dans
ce coin au bord de la route il y a des
cache-couilles des peluches accrochées
aux arbres et même des valises
visiblement pour montrer le chemin à
prendre c'est pas plus d'un entrer dans
la forêt si ce sont des forêts qui ont
vécu le verglin il y a plein d'herbes
par terre partout c'est vraiment
dangereux l'autre côté existe on va
peut-être en parler un peu plus parce
qu'il y a un homme qui est mort
[Musique]
le corps de Fritz nail Richard a été
retrouvé ici le 4 janvier danse boisé à
quelques centaines de mètres à peine du
chemin Roxane il serait mort de froid
après cette perdue durant la tempête qui
a connu le Québec à la fin descendre
fritznell faisait partie des 40 000
personnes arrivées au Canada par Roxane
depuis près d'un an c'est loin d'être
cas isolé je connais au moins 10
personnes ou bien des couples et autres
qui sont retournés depuis
novembre 2021 Franz André aide les
demandeurs d'asile depuis plusieurs
années le rêve canadien serait
malheureusement devenu parfois amirage
je crois que le Canada est un bon pays
d'accueil par contre depuis maintenant
la covid les choses se sont compliquées
amener les gens justement à être
désespérés puis prendre des décisions
qu'ils auraient peut-être pas dû prendre
c'est en contact avec la femme de
fitnell elle aussi elle a quitté le
Canada avec l'aide d'un passeur en
passant par ses bois mais pendant
l'automne ça coûte combien de faire
appel à un passeur de ce pour retourner
aux Etats-Unis ça peut aller jusqu'au
1500 dollars et plus c'est qu'on force
d'une certaine façon les gens à franchir
la frontière de cette façon là selon cet
avocat ces Migros seraient prêts à payer
et prendre beaucoup de risques pour
entrer aux États-Unis faites la
clientèle elle est différente les gens
qui passent par le chemin Roxane ce sont
des gens qui veulent être pris en charge
par les autorités canadiennes alors que
ceux qui veulent traverser du côté
américain c'est tout à fait l'inverse
eux ne veulent pas être pris par les
autorites américaines ils veulent se
fondre dans la nature et malheureusement
ils sont prêts à emprunter des voix qui
sont pas toujours sécuritaires malgré
les dangers beaucoup y pensent et
beaucoup le font il suffit de rester un
peu au bord de la frontière loin des
policiers du chemin Roxane pour le
constater
pour personne qui te voient il y en a de
plus en plus des petits carrés de
blanche
des sous dans les poches avec la vie des
autres puis de malheur des autres et moi
je trouve ça d'une tristesse infinie ici
romain Suez Radio-Canada et mingford